yeah what caused you to stop for good
uh
all right
[Music]
I was in an induced coma for for about
five days what yeah what happened I
don't know I really don't know he just
went into a coma yeah I I
was fine and then I woke up at a
hospital when was this uh
four or five years ago
that's gonna be the most terrifying
thing for you your family oh it was not
good it was just after my wedding
you had just gotten married I just got
married
and you went to a do you remember where
you were when you did this happen
apparently I was in the house that we
got married and why and was in the house
in Hawaii
and uh the night before had gotten a bit
Rowdy and I'd been throwing some
relatives out of the house because they
were Behaving Badly
and uh I got a retired and I I lay on
the couch apparently and went to sleep
and it just looked like I was sleeping
and then um my my now wife noticed that
I should have woken up by now and I
hadn't so they um
yeah it kind of looks so short I ended
up uh in a hospital in Hawaii
and I was in induce karma for
like seven days something like that they
didn't know anything they weren't even
sure they were telling her we're not
sure he's coming out of it
and they don't know what caused it
really not really they don't really
they're not really sure
but I think it was like
I run myself pretty hard
do you know like I was I was smoking
then I just I don't sleep much
um you stress when I no I'm not a
stressor but you don't sleep it's weird
it's people that stress usually don't
sleep no I just don't sleep I like the
night
and what I find is that
my days are usually like kind of full
with other people's [__] like my [__]
podcast yeah but people you know like
remember my family you know my daughter
whatever
um
feeling the stuff I like to do and so
like I find in my day isn't my day
or whenever it hits midnight and
everyone's going to bed that's my time
and then I can just sit back relax
don't
have to think about work or anyone else
or anyone else
and
it depends you know and initially I
would read
but then then my eyesight started
getting a bit shitty
um and uh I love these stories yeah so
if you quit after the coma you came out
you stopped smoking yeah absolutely that
was it you're like I'm done how many
yeah that was it and um and if that
doesn't make you quit then you know then
you're on your own
um anyway so I was I was I wasn't
allowed to leave Hawaii
uh for about five weeks I think wow and
I was so desperate I was so desperate to
leave but you know when you go into one
of those uh when you go into a discommer
when I came out
like I could remember almost everything
but the most amazing thing about it was
what I remembered the most is that I had
the most amazing
dreams hallucinations I remember them to
a day to this day that was so
fantastic when I woke up I said how many
hospitals have I been in because I
thought that I had been to Zurich I'd
been on a private plane flying to
hospitals in Zurich in Germany I thought
I'd done like seven hospitals wow it
felt like eternity in my head no no I
mean it was quite an interesting trip
like and I kept meeting these kind of
bizarre people
in this in that state that I was in it
was very lucid actually and there were
times that
I
would come out of that dream state and I
could see people that I knew but I
couldn't communicate with them
that was a little odd that was like
being stuck inside this glass bowl could
you ever see yourself like lying in a
bed yeah I did because that they say is
like when you're passing or like where
you're almost close to passing a lot of
people will see that and when I saw I
didn't see myself okay so he was always
there myself I was in a German clinic
and I had this crazy female German
Doctor Who was like Bauhaus kind of
thing
no no change of time but we had this new
treatment for you and it was like this
because I was like what I remember it
was hot all the time right and she said
we have this eye suit that you must put
on
it was a blow-up suit that it was very
very chilled and but it was quite
uncomfortable hands and I saw it it was
Iceland very uncomfortable to there it
was not made by Hugo Boss that's for
sure